jetliners are basically flying homes
it's a sealed pressure canister it's
incredibly strong
it will last practically forever
i'm bruce campbell and you're inside the
cockpit area of my 727 home
i can appreciate that some folks might
feel a bit isolated or that it might
simply strike them as an unusual living
environment but for me it's always felt
completely natural
my entry is via the aft air stairs which
are retractable and are retracted
whenever i leave for an extended time
the aft area of the aircraft now is my
living space
my very primitive shower is located
there
the two natural aft laboratories are
both functional
sleeping quarters are there in the form
of a simple futon sofa and bench where i
spend lots of time embellishing elements
of the aircraft
jetliners retire at the rate of about
three per day
for the most part i think we shred them
and then we spin around 180 degrees and
make a home after having just shredded
an aerospace class home sized structure
if you were an extraterrestrial looking
down on this behavior you'd wonder
whether the species has all its marbles
in place or not
people have asked me
whether it crashed here and i simply
restored the wreck
that's an odd thing to hear it's it's
completely
impractical
next time you're in a jetliner close
your eyes for a moment in your mind
remove all the seats and all the other
people
and then open your eyes with that vision
and consider the the expanse of the
living room
it's a good environment it really is
what do you say to people who just say
this is not a normal way of living
thank you very much
i'm catherine and this is my husband
wayne i'm wayne and welcome to freedom
coat
we live in a secluded cove
the only option we have to get here is
by water there are no road accesses
the water is our highway
everything that you see here
in our home is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored
we have our main living house
we have the dance floor
the lighthouse building
four greenhouses
as i started to grow the garden and make
it larger then we had to have more space
for that garden
everything's done with a hand saw and
hammer
no power tools i know every board and
nail by name
it's about 500 tons
a million pounds when i'm flowing
i've been building tree forts since i
was seven and i said well dad i'm
putting a tree fort in the ocean
do you ever get seasick
no when i go to town i get land sick
the thing about living in clockwood
sound on the west coast of vancouver
island it's the richest biomass on earth
so the opportunity to fish for dinner is
big
and i just can get in my canoe and
paddle out in 10 minutes i can catch a
fish
but when it's windy and too too rough
out there i can lay on the couch and
fish out of the house
i was hoping to make a lot more money as
an artist
so subsistence living was our only
opportunity to have anything as artists
we could never buy real estate so we had
to make our own
it was a great opportunity to actually
move away from the city to see if we
could
prosper out here
now 24 years later we're still doing it
i can't imagine living any other way
i feel completely fulfilled
oh that's good
that's really nice
i'm working on it
for somebody driving into town the first
time you wouldn't think there was a lot
here because
95 of it is hiding underground
people drive in and go
where is the place i don't understand
kuberpedi is from the aboriginal
pity which means white man in a hole
at the moment upstairs it is about
122 degrees fahrenheit down here we're
sitting on about 71 72 degrees no air
conditioning necessary we're right out
in the middle of nowhere it takes a day
to drive here from adelaide i'd say
there's about
a thousand underground dwellings and
at least 1500 people living underground
we've got five underground churches
we've got underground motels there's
some amazing underground homes here many
bedrooms underground workshop you name
it underground we've pretty well got it
i bought my dugout as a
fairly small two-bedroom dugout and i've
been extending it over the years some of
this i blasted out
when i could get away with it the cops
don't like us blasting in town we don't
do it anymore
back in the old days if somebody was
gonna have a baby we'd rock around there
with a couple of compressors on a
weekend and some jackhammers and a
couple of cartons of beer and by the
sunday night we dug out a room cemented
the floor and wired it up and uh there's
your new babies room honey
even though we're so far away
geographically from anywhere else
i don't know why but we just love the
place to bits
this is my friend laura and she's 80
years old
and this is my friend tiffany and she is
26.
and we live in a retirement community
i'm a part of the artisan residence
program at judson manor which is a
residential program where young
musicians get to live here rent free in
exchange for performing recitals and
concerts
when i tell people i live in the
retirement community i get a lot of
mixed reactions some people don't
believe me other people
think it's a wonderful idea
i had not been
a part of this community more than
two days
i was in the lobby and they told me
about tiffany and i walked over and
introduced myself and i said do you like
dogs
oh she loves dogs
and tiffany and i became friends we just
formed a friendship
we'll talk about art we talk about
clothes
i don't wear shoe fashionable shoes
anymore but tiffany does and we talk
about shoes
laura to me is
like a grandma
and also a friend and a confidant
i don't think the age difference is
something that i am constantly thinking
about or that i'm aware of you don't
think oh i'm having dinner with this 100
year old and this 90 year old you know
i'm having dinner with my friend laura
and sarah
in a way it is almost like being in a
college dorm with the fact that there's
so many people here
from different places from different
backgrounds it might be a little bit
quieter
than a normal college dorm
but i think we still have just as much
fun
home for me first of all is a piece of
mind where you come home and you're
always safe
that's what home means to me especially
for my children
before i moved into this home six months
ago i was living in a shelter to get my
own home it was just breathtaking but
there was nothing in it
i'm kristen sui and i'm a designer at
hummel design
everything in this warehouse you see is
donated
we work with homeless and domestic abuse
shelters with families that are moving
out of those shelters and into homes and
a lot of times they have nothing but the
clothes on their back that's where we
step in and we provide the furniture for
them but then we also go back and
decorate and provide like those little
details that make your house a home and
makes it your home
without our help about 46 percent of
families coming out of the shelter go
right back in with our help that
statistics goes down to one percent
i'm a direct care worker and i work with
older elder people
before i lived in the shelter the
boyfriend that i was living with was
emotionally and physically abusive to me
one day i woke up and i just said i
wasn't taking that anymore
today we met with danielle and we just
talked um
with her a little bit found out about
her backstory it sounds like she has
come out of the shelter and now has been
in a house with basically no furniture
she has a few pieces but no beds no you
know chairs no table
so we talked with her a little bit about
what she wants in her home we went to
the the home we took measurements
and just walked through each room
what dinner looks at my house now we all
sit together but we sit on the floor the
priorities was to have like silverware
bowls and spoons stuff some things for
us to eat out of and
bedding to put on the floor for us
because we didn't have beds
when i first started here i didn't
realize that people were living this way
when you walk into a home that is
completely empty and families are living
there and have lived there for months
it's shocking because you don't think of
it
but on that friday when we reveal a
house i just i just love the energy
from our volunteers to the families that
are getting these you know
new homes really
i just i can't get enough of that
feeling and that's why i've stayed here
for for so long
i know my kids are going to be amazed
because i haven't really told them
what's going on i just told them they
was getting some bed so they don't even
know that the whole house is going to be
done
so i know they're going to be astounded
so it just makes me very happy
it's like a magazine
went from zero to a miracle
i love y'all for this i mean this is
amazing
it's just happiness to me to be able to
walk into a home and have your friends
and family there and you're able to just
show them comfort and joy that means a
lot to me and i hope that one day i can
give back just what was given to me
you